When it comes to solving equations, we've learned a lot of different techniques
to solve the quadratic ones. We saw the square root method, where we could take
the square root of both sides of the equation. We used plus or minus to
indicate the positive and negative root for this side. So here, x could equal
positive or negative 3. We also could set the equation equal to 0 by
subtracting 9 from both sides. This led us to factor. We could factor x squared
minus 9 as the difference of 2 squares. So we have x minus 3 times x plus 3.
Setting each factor equal to 0, we would get x could equal positive 3 or
negative 3. So the square root method and factoring were two of the tools in
our arsenal to solve this type of equation. We could even use the quadratic
formula. If we subtract 9 from both sides. We'll have x squared minus 9 equals
0. This equation has an a value of 1. A b value of 0. And a c value of negative
9. If we plug in 0 for b in the quadratic formula. And a value of 1 and a c
value of negative 9. This evaluates to plus or minus 3. Notice that any way we
solve the original equation, we still get the same answers. Plus or minus 3
each time.